[Musique]
bonsoir à tous début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale avec tva 78
très heureux de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du journal tout
de suite les titres de ce lundi 5
novembre
c'est notre fil rouge jusqu'à jeudi le
dossier de la rédaction est consacrée à
la thématique des déserts médicaux
en six ans le département a perdu 109
médecins généralistes quelle est la
situation actuelle sur le territoire et
à saint quentin en yvelines
éléments de réponse à suivre la tendance
semble séduire les versaillais le marché
notre dame propose désormais un quart
est tourné vers le bio une quinzaine de
commerçants est regroupé maraîchers
boucherie ou encore biscuiterie et ce
dimanche nous commémorons le centenaire
de l'armistice de 1918 marquant la fin
de la première guerre mondiale
un devoir de mémoire entretenu notamment
par pharma citoyens l'association de
trappes a emmené elle la semaine
dernière une vingtaine de jeunes à
verdun son président mustapha larbaoui
est notre invité avant de développer ces
titres nous l'avons appris ce matin
l'ancien député des yvelines jacques
masdeu-arus est mort ce dimanche à l'âge
de 76 ans est maire de poissy entre 1983
et 2008 il a été parlementaire pendant
21 ans jusqu'en 2009 et déchu cette
année là de son mandat de corruption de
son mandat pour corruption passive
une peine d'inéligibilité avaient été
prononcé à son égard retiré de la vie
politique jacques masdeu-arus été
gravement touchées par la maladie
d'alzheimer
cette semaine donc que consacrons notre
dossier de la rédaction sur les zones
médicale sous denses dans le département
et à saint quentin en yvelines ce soir
posons le contexte pour commencer vous
allez découvrir est la situation de
l'offre sur le territoire nombre de
médecins généralistes et de spécialistes
densité par habitant ou encore les
communes en manque deux praticiens c'est
avec ce reportage de nicolas d'andré les
yvelines troisième département d'île de
france concernant le nombre de médecins
le territoire yvelinois compte 2068
médecin 2008 généralistes selon les
chiffres de l'agencé régionale de santé
l'âge moyen est de 53 à 59 ans et pour
les spécialistes la moyenne atteint 64 5
ans
avec un impact sur l'évolution entre
2011 et 2017 l'écart entre les
praticiens entrants et sortants
s'accroît en six ans les yvelines ont
perdu 109 généraliste et 154
spécialistes une situation expliquée par
la non compensation des départs à la
retraite des médecins ne peuvent plus
répondre à la demande de la population
sachant qu'en même temps que le déficit
s'accroît c'est en dans les yvelines de
la population augmenter et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec des
grosses difficultés de prise en charge
des patients
la rs classe des communes en deux
catégories en fonction du nombre de
médecins par habitant
les ips zone d'intervention prioritaire
et les axes zone d'action
complémentaires dans les yvelines et
communes rurales sont principalement
classé en zip actuellement 178 médecins
exercent sur saint quentin en yvelines
132 médecins généralistes et 46 médecins
spécialistes sur les douze communes 8
sont concernés par le classement de la
rs notamment les clayes-sous-bois trappe
et la verrière classé en zone
d'intervention prioritaire
les villes qui se sont le plus
industrialisés ont vu d'abord dans les
années 60-70 s'installer les médecins et
ceux qui sont enceintes installées dans
les années 1970 sont en train de partir
et après les nouvelles communes taille
type briancourt elancourt les médecins
sont arrivés plus tard se sont installés
plus tard et donc partiront plus tard
donc le déficit qui apparaît
actuellement il est surtout sur ces
communes où l'installation s'est faite
dans les années 70 classés en zip ou
razak les communes peuvent bénéficier
des aides pour attirer des médecins et
les praticiens s'installant dans ces
zones disposent d'accompagnement c'est
d'abord le contrat d' aides à
l'installation des médecins ce qu'on
appelle le kaïm qu'il a est accessible
dans les iep et
pour les médecins qui s'installent en
première installation qui permet un
financement à hauteur de 50 mais le
rouge c'est le contrat de praticiens
territoriale de médecine générale
le pt mg qui hélas est accessible autant
dans les zac que dans les iep ans et qui
permet de garantir un revenu brut
mensuel de 6900 euros
d'autres mesures peuvent être aussi
envisagées le gouvernement a engagé une
réforme sur le sujet ma santé 2022
nous vous en parlons depuis quelques
semaines sur tv 78 une élection
municipale partielle est programmée à
coignières les dimanches 25 novembre et
2 décembre un scrutin rendu nécessaire
après la démission du maire jean-pierre
sevestre et de plusieurs élus et nous
recevons sur ce plateau les différentes
listes candidates
bonsoir nicolas robe bon sens monsieur
vous êtes l'un des colistiers de la
liste au coeur de coignières c'est une
liste qui se veut sans appartenance
politique on va y revenir
on ne connaît pas encore votre tête de
liste vous indiquer vouloir choisir une
tête de liste une fois que vous aurez
choisi voilà trouver des vingt-sept
colistiers le dépôt des listes la fin du
dépôt de ses listes doivent se faire
avant la fin de la semaine est ce que
vous allez pouvoir aligner une liste de
27 colistiers nous n'avons encore pas le
quota des vingt-sept et il nous en reste
très axe exactement 8
d'accord mais nous ne désespérons pas me
fera que nous sommes pas les seuls dans
ce cas là donc jusqu'au bout on
démarchera c'est vrai que 108 colistiers
à trouver sur une commune de 2300
électeurs
la charge est dure mais voilà on a
démarré un petit peu tard mais on compte
rattraper le retard et si on prend pas
le départ ce ne sera pas une catastrophe
puisqu'on propose quand même quelque
chose qui nous semble essentiel et qui
sera peut être portée et qui aura
peut-être un avenir c'est une démarche
alors vous allez nous expliquer vous
êtes l'initiateur du coût de cette
démarche aux côtés d'eric giraudet qui
est conseiller municipal indépendant
pourquoi justement se lancer dans cette
démarche
alors on se lance dans cette démarche
parce que suit toutes les agitations qui
ont eu lieu à coignières depuis la
nouvelle élection de cette mandature
en fait ça va de mal en pis c'était dur
avec des parts dans ipa yeux l'ancien
maire 15 en 2015
la succession a été difficile il ya eu
beaucoup de tension et ces tensions
soyez crescendo puisque des conseillers
municipaux se sont séparés de leur liste
d'élections qui était quoi il ya
démocratie
bon et puis avec des traitements en
détention et des manières de débattre
qui en parlait de débat mais il n'y
avait jamais de débat c'était vraiment
très compliqué donc il s'avérait qu'il
fallait faire les choses différemment et
dire mais voilà on va proposer une vraie
démocratie participative
on va vraiment aller vers les gens
vraiment savoir ce qu'ils veulent quand
on représente à la fois la fonction
d'élu quand il s'agit de représenter
l'état dans la commune on va vraiment
faire avoir une démarche d'explication
avec la population et pas de toujours
une charge d'imposition
vous parliez des détentions justement
qui se sont vus qui ont été à leur
apogée au moment du projet de fusion
avec nos repas c'est au printemps un
projet qui a été ensuite abandonnés on a
vu des tensions au sein de la majorité
des conseils municipaux également
houleux avec voilà beaucoup de tension
notamment des personnes qui ont assisté
à ce à ses conseils il faut revenir au
calme aujourd'hui à coignières c'est la
priorité
alors c'est vrai que là je parlais plus
du fond qui a fait notre notre émergence
mais la forme est vraiment très
discourtoise c'est presque intolérable
d'avoir des comportements comme ça dans
des conseils municipaux de réclamé des
démissions des choses comme ça avec
autant de violence
on a entendu
dans l'assemblée les gens qui ont
assisté au conseil de réclamer la
démission de jean pierre sauvestre qui
était hier c'était s'étaient organisés
certes il avait pas il avait pêché par
manque d'anticipation part d une une
information trop tardive et ça depuis le
pays est lui quand il y en a parlé
c'était déjà trop tard pour lancer les
premières démarches
là il ya eu la piscine de maurepas il ya
une petite
on peut dire que ce progrès de fusion
dans la démarche qui a été vendue comme
déjà tout fait et c'était intolérable
dans la dont principalement dans la
démarche ça va empêcher de réfléchir
alors qu'il y avait forcément une
transition culture est bon donc on s'est
mis aussi positionné contre ce projet de
fusion effective
la liste qui sera élu en novembre ou en
décembre s'il ya un deuxième tour aura
un mandat assez court finalement puisque
les prochaines élections municipales
sont programmées en 2020 c'est quoi
aujourd'hui les dossiers prioritaires
sur lequel il faut s'atteler à quoi
alors en démarchant auprès de la
population il ya principalement deux
dossiers qui relèvent attention c'est le
transport et l'emploi bon et bien sûr il
ya pas que ça il ya aussi de
l'urbanisation de certains coins qui est
insatisfaisante
il ya aussi l'éducation c'est un peu lié
à l'emploi
mais bon voilà en lioret un premier
effet obtenir assez rapide avec assez
peu de coups sur l'emploi et
principalement le transport l'exercice
budgétaire sera très court donc il faut
à précipiter les choses pour réussir à
faire quelque chose dans ce qui n'est
pas prévu dans ce qui a été relaté par
manque de concertation donc ceci sous
jacente à rattraper mais le dernier mot
il nous reste moins d'une minute sur sur
la lys justement revenons à cette liste
initiée notamment par eric giraudet
conseiller municipal indépendant par
vous l'idée c'est quoi c'est de faire
participer les quoi n'y a rien qui ait
des habitants dans cette liste oui tout
à fait on fait participer des coignard
rien c'est pour ça qu'on va leur
rencontre pour chercher des gens
nouveaux qui veulent participer au débat
et à la vie de la politique locale
ça ça me semble essentiel il ya beaucoup
de gens qui sont capables de faire des
choses c'est pas un métier à part
entière on est comme une commune de 4300
habitants c'est c'est pas énorme il ya
moyen de faire simplement de de la
politique locale est en bonne
intelligence base de bon sens de
transparence il devrait établir cette
confiance qui aujourd'hui est quand même
complètement disparu et je pense que
c'est pas fini on n'a pas fini de voir
et je vous apparaître merci nicolas robe
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et je
rappelle que vous êtes l'un des
colistiers de la liste apolitique au
coeur de coignières premier tour de
cette municipale partielle le 25
novembre en éventuel deuxième tour et
lui a programmé le 2 décembre le reste
de l'actualité en bref deux cent mille
et saunier yvelinois affecté par une
grève de la collecte des ordures
mouvement illimité à l'appel de la cgt
qui perturbe le ramassage des poubelles
dans les communes adhérentes au siom
notamment saint rémy les chevreuse et
chevreuse en cause est la reprise du
marché de collecte par la société secure
d'après le syndicat les salariés vont
perdre en moyenne de 250 à 300 euros par
mois avec ce changement et des
boucheries des yvelines de nouveau prise
à partie vendredi deux établissements
situés à versailles ont été visés par
des agents anti spéciste ses militants
de la cause animale et du faux sang a
été jeté sur les devantures et le
chiffre
269 a été inscrit au marqueur rouge sur
les vitrines 269 en référence à
l'association antispécistes 269
libération animale est des actes de
vandalisme similaires ont eu lieu
également à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et
dans la ville de jouy en josas à
versailles toujours des enseignes
spécialisées des magasins en vrac et des
restaurateurs de plus en plus et
demandeurs la cité royale
elles se mettent au bio pour suivre la
tendance la municipalité a regroupé est
les commerçants bio du marché notre dame
dans un même carré les explications de
marie lehn iapichino et de patrie
jacques de dixmude
chaque semaine ce versailles il retrouve
son stand du marché préféré j'ai mes
habitudes ici parce que les produits
seront authentique
ce sont des produits qui sont en partie
bio tout comme et on les teste on a
testé à peu près tout ce qu'ils font et
à chaque fois on revient
particulièrement chez ce commerçant
merci beaucoup
petit à petit le carré à la viande du
marché notre-dame de versailles est
devenu un carré bio l'idée de suivre les
habitudes de consommation des habitants
c'est une clientèle très fidèle quand le
produit est bon et qui revient donc on a
une clientèle depuis plus d'un an et
demi extrêmement finale dès 2011 la
ville de versailles avait essayé de
mettre en place un marché bio quartier
saint louis une idée peut-être trop
avant gardiste à l'époque mais une vraie
demande aujourd'hui la tendance
nationale étant là on a voulu vraiment
étoffé l'extrême qualité déjà du marché
notre dame en continuant à poursuivre
son extension
le regroupement permet une meilleure
identification pour le client et attire
les commerçants la ville reçoit de plus
en plus de demandes pour faire partie du
carré réservé je préside une commission
quatre fois par an et on valide les
demandes en fonction de la qualité des
dossiers qui nous sont présentés
la sélection se fait également dans un
objectif de pluralité de l'offre
quinze commerçants variés sont présents
dans ce cas les bios des sorties sur le
thème de la mémoire pendant les vacances
une vingtaine de jeunes de trappes s'est
rendue dans deux lieux le mémorial de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé à nantes et à
verdun à quelques jours de la
commémoration de l'armistice signé en
1918 bonsoir monsieur falardeau ici dans
sa lettre le président de formats
citoyens c'est votre association qui a
emmené ses jeunes mais aussi des adultes
aux donc ces jeunes pardon c'est des
jeunes du club de trappes alors avant de
parler de la sortie à nantes au mémorial
de l'abolition de l'esclavagé
vous avez les dix ans nées ces jeunes à
verdun c'est le lieu d'une des plus
emblématiques bataille de la première
guerre mondiale qui a eu lieu donc en
1916 l'une des plus meurtrières aussi
cette bataille de verdun plus de 300000
mans plus de 400 mille blessés
c'était important pour vous de
d'expliquer à ces jeunes de les emmener
d'expliquer pourquoi on commémore
aujourd'hui ces dates
en fait ce qui est important pour nous
cessons pharma citoyens c'est que on a
envie de tout d'aller à la rencontre de
nos de nos enfants pour qu'ils
apprennent des choses celle qu'ils
apprennent à l'école est là l'idée c'est
de sortir pour aller sur des lieux à la
fois de mémoire mais c'est pas non plus
les emmener sur des cimetières pour les
emmener sur des cimetières
il ya vraiment l'idée selon laquelle la
société compte dans laquelle on vit tous
elle n'est pas le fruit du hasard elle
est celle que l'on construit et je dis
souvent que c'est celle des adultes et
les enfants ce sont ceux avec lesquels
sur lesquels on travaille donc en fait
les enfants deviennent seulement ce
qu'on a bien voulu et je crois que il ya
beaucoup à faire au niveau des adultes
sur les enfants sur ce travail de 1 de
mémoire mais pas simplement pour les
victimes et pas paix à leurs âmes mais
mais aussi mais c'est surtout le futur
qui me reste pour la droite il en
faisant en faisant tout ça c'est en été
sur le futur que je travaille mais a
continué comme on l'entend en permanence
moi j'écoute la télé tout le monde
écoute la télé la radio c'est anxiogène
on va finir par soutenir la gueule il
faut peut-être qu'on avance un petit peu
d'une manière d'une manière enfin
autrement on va tous ces voyages cet
esprit de solidarité tous ces voyages
c'est exactement ça c'est voilà ce que
la connerie humaine peut apporter
nantes c'est la traite négrière qui est
une une abomination de 2,2 ce que l'être
humain peut faire la guerre qui part
d'une connerie à sarajevo pour le dire
vite fait une crèmerie vaduz conçoit
bien s'énonce et d'émilie moment on se
pose des questions demain ça peut
arriver avec une connerie qui peut
arriver et donc tout ça c'est pour dire
que la connerie humaine en transe elle
entre les cas celle sur laquelle j'ai
envie de parler peut provoquer des
choses beaucoup plus dramatique et
l'utiliser c'est aussi les ouvrir à
autre chose c'est des footeux c'est
également wallace et les ouvrir à
d'autres d'autres thèmes a élargi lors
que l'enflure je suis donc j'ai été
président pendant 14 ans du club de foot
de trappes
aujourd'hui je continue à être président
d'honneur mais ça te souhaiter un
prétexte pour moi le foot pour faire
autre chose
mais ce qui m'intéresse c'est le sport
et la culture c'est vraiment de 2
pendant important pour pourra pour aller
toucher l'âme des citoyens et faire en
sorte que les enfants grandissent sondés
sur des vecteurs et des valeurs
importantes
donc ouais c'est un prétexte et l'idée
c'est de sortir mais sait jamais des
sorties on va dire qu'on sommative on
n'y va pas je vais pas les emmener au
bord de la mer ni à la montagne c'est
super important joué tout ça c'est
important mais ça peut être fait par
d'autres
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est d emmener
sur des lieux ou de mémoire ou
d'histoire éducative de toute façon avec
une réflexion et qu'ils en gardent
simplement un mot une phrase une idée
juste pour vous dire 40 on était 40 y
avait 27 gamins à verdun par exemple la
visite se fait en une heure et demie on
est on est resté vingt minutes à
attendre une gamine qui voulait tout
voir tout lire on en est tous sortis
il s'est vraiment passé quelque chose à
ce moment là pour celles-là m'arrêter se
passe quelque chose pour tous à nombre
de la même façon voilà et puis fermé
citoyens c'est également une classe là
aujourd'hui par exemple on a fait le
ramassage scolaire d'accord on les
emmène en classe on leur paye un goûter
et après on travaille sur la
concentration sur l'estimé de soi ont
fait durant formate français mais je
reste convaincu que techniquement ils
sont capables comme tout le monde c'est
évident c'est même ridicule de le dire
de dire autre chose mais travailler sur
l'estimé de soi
c'est ce qu'on fait et sur la
concentration mettre en avant des
talents on sait que la ville de trappes
de la ville de trappes héberge de
nombreux talents et j'aimerais que ça
soit qu'on est face émergée surtout de
bons citoyens parce que la citoyenneté
c'est devenir ce que l'on doit être
petit personnel donc on travaille sur
soi mais c'est également travailler en
collectif et donc il ya des valeurs
comme ça sur laquelle on travaille
beaucoup
des notions de république quand du sens
la laïcité et les mixités on emmène
toujours des seniors avec nous donc la
mixité ménages pour filles et garçons
et demain sur des quartiers différents
comme la verrière où jussieu le quartier
de jussieu à versailles ce sont les
trois quartiers sur lesquels j'ai
travaillé et j'en profite pour vous
remercier téléphiles parce que je suis
ému en en parlant je suis ému de parler
tout ça parce que c'est
voilà c'est des choses qui me touchent
beaucoup qui nous tiennent à coeur donc
je vous remercie infiniment parce que il
faut faire et on s'en contente
mais il faut le faire savoir aussi parce
que j'ai besoin que d'autres nous
rejoignent que des bénévoles et on aura
une quinzaine de sorties dans l'année
donc cinq voyages important on a prévu
le dvd des musées en ile de france
également comme le musée de la shoah
comme d'autres mémoires importantes qui
ont vraiment brisé pour moi en belgique
pour le coup tragique mais par contre y
en aura d'autres on ira futuroscope
oui on ira sur des lieux où on apprend
mais un peu plus un peu plus festif
quand même donc c'est à la fois les
sortir ça c'est important
il se passe jamais rien dimanche par le
foot on les sort aussi les dimanches et
c'est ça cette idée c'est le foot c'est
bien mais il reste quand même assignée à
résidence avec le foot c'est quand même
un peu dans leur quartier ou dans
d'autres quartiers
donc j'ai envie qu'ils sortent aussi
ailleurs et sur cette sortie est
justement un nom de voulais y revenir à
ce mémorial de l'abolition de
l'esclavagé skull et les jeunes soient
au courant de cette histoire où ou pas
du tout cette histoire tragique de
france et du monde
très peu le sont les enfants très peu
j'ai presque envie de dire que la
plupart de ceux qui nous écoutent ce
soir et les adultes en particulier ne
savent pas grand chose
j'ai moi même appris beaucoup de choses
et c'est très prenant
donc l'idée c'est pas de encore une fois
c'est pas de trouver ni des fautifs ni
ni de faire quelque commentaire que ce
soit c'est juste que ces choses-là ont
existé traite négrière lachor où les
guerres meurtrières ont existé
souvent c'est la connerie humaine il ya
vraiment moyen de faire autrement
et bien sûr ce qui nous intéresse
maintenant le thème qui nous intéresse
en particulier c'est la transition
écologique
donc on travaille avec nos mômes sur nos
enfants sur l'estimé de soi la
concentration et puis faire en sorte que
des gestes soient appris
au sein de pharma citoyens voilà le
programme est vaste mais en réalité on
est focalisé sur ce que nos enfants
peuvent apprendre l'éducation c'est aux
parents l'école à ce travail et les
associations comme les nôtres viennent
en relais le peu qu'on fera on est bien
content de le faire parce que je me sens
responsable de tout ce qui se passe sur
la planète même si je suis pas coupable
il voulait dire travailler sur l'avenir
merci à vous stafa larbaoui d'avoir une
présidente format citoyens et nous
reparlerons de ce thème de la
commémoration des 100 ans de l'armistice
l'armistice ce jeudi dans le journal
avec des invités le sport pardon le
sport le départ de la route du rhum a
été donné hier dimanche depuis le sport
de saint malo les skippers se sont
élancés pour rejoindre la guadeloupe en
solitaire parmi eux deux et binoy louis
burton originaire de rambouillet à éric
bellion est de versailles est le premier
a pris la route sur son imoca bureau
vallée mais son aventure pourrait
rapidement se terminer le skipper est
actuellement en train de réparer son
bateau à roscoff suite à une avarie et à
l'heure où je vous parle pas de problème
a priori en revanche pour éric bellion
le skipper comme un seul homme de comme
un seul homme est 14e au classement dans
les bateaux hors catégorie on continue
de parler sport dans cette émission avec
mickey l'ennemi domont soir sans grégory
comme chaque lundi vous venez nous
présenter les principaux résultats du
week end dans le département
et on commence michael par un sport qui
vous plaît je le sais c'est le volley
ball
je peux rien vous cacher un grégory je
vais vous emmener du côté de
vélizy-villacoublay tous les signaux
sont au vert pour l'équipe féminine
senior en nationale 3 ce week-end les
bélizienne sont imposés dans leur
gymnase trois sets à zéro elles ont
remporté leur cinquième victoire de la
saison en six matches disputés le score
25 à 20 25 11 et 25 à 8
écoutez érection balade de santé
dans le premier set n'était pas la
réalité plutôt série justement c'est en
psycho logiquement se met dedans et
après par la suite effectivement ça
s'est érodée on a été plus propre dans
le fond que je cède comme satisfait par
rapport à la causerie d'avant match
justement on a essayé d'appuyer sur le
fait de jouer ensemble se faire plaisir
et de tenir le jeu qu'on a pas tenu sur
les derniers max dans la régularité
donc bonne réaction des filles avec
cette victoire allait bélizienne
conserve la première place du
championnat de nationale 3 devant
argenteuil
mais le promu le sens flamme bah écoutez
donc l'installer c'est une année de
plaisir où maintenant les filles
commencent à chercher justement à faire
des résultats
mais les objectifs du club
ces deux mois ci c'est au maintien mois
céder ses dauphins le tableau est plus
ça va et plus ici sont gourmandes donc
on va voir pour continuer à rêver d'une
montée en nationale 2 vélizy devra
s'imposer le 17 novembre prochain face à
son dauphin au classement argenteuil
après un sport de balle un sport
collectif mais qu'elle y avait également
du football seront jouées en première
division de district 6e journée à ce
week-end plaisir s'est imposé dans la
douleur 2-1 contre marly le roi lui en
cours domine sartrouville 3-2 maurepas
s'incline 3 à 0 contre où il y à
l'extérieur c'était un jour les portes
ouvertes en revanche vous aurez défense
de montesson les gens ont pris l'eau sur
le terrain de carrière grésillons 10 à 1
et grise comme on l'appelle valises
c'est exactement le chesnais s'offrent
le fc mantois mois le fc mantois 4 à 3
dans un festival offensif enfin à
gargenville s'impose contre hardricourt
3 le championnat est dominé à part lui
en cours merci michael et on retrouvera
tous ces résultats dans votre émission
de 7 8 ports c'est ça avec les instants
à suivre sur sur kyle et 78 on termine
en musique avec le festival de fès qui
s'est déroulée ce week-end un événement
métal à voisins le bretonneux et à
rambouillet sur scène huit groupes
parfois venus de loin immersion avec
manon varaldo et patrick jacques de
dixmude
human toys red sky ou encore stone
belote
chaque groupe essaye de faire partager
son monde son univers un peu geek de
plus en plus nombreux au festival donne
first composition temps psychédélique
seventies saturation de la guitare
rythme très long très lent les baby
viper ont fait le déplacement depuis
perpignan
ils ont fait découvrir les titres de
leur dernier album c'est important pour
nous de se répandre en fait deux
un petit peu de faire connaître un petit
peu à droite à gauche chez puis de
montrer un petit peu cyniquement de quoi
on est capable
et voilà comme je les dis d'honorer
justement cet album nous avons sorti
d'on dont nous sommes vraiment très
fiers
pour la deuxième édition les
organisateurs de dancers vous voulu
donner une dimension internationale et
festivals contrairement à l'année
dernière où c'était beaucoup plus local
je voulais c'est le programme est un peu
des exclus et latika qu'ils ont pas joué
depuis des années et changé une fois en
france c'était à chaque camp d'une 14,3
en bretagne et depuis longtemps joué
dessus depuis et je trouvais ça dommage
parce que c'est un mot qui est un groupe
qui fait un peu la fusion avec les
croyances amérindienne des voix ethnique
et tout ça je trouvais ça super
intéressant et voilà ça super énergique
et s'échauffent si c'est une musique
faut faire découvrir aux gens le stoner
attire les raids scalp polonais ont des
sonorités amérindiennes avec des voix
est nick nous nous trouvons là où il ya
des festivals internationaux c'est sympa
bien évidemment ils sont très
intéressants mais nous aimons les deux
les festivals internationaux en pologne
aussi les groupes locaux
je pense qu'on mixant les deux c'est la
meilleure façon et subway
le métal a donc ses admirateurs dans les
yvelines un style musical en plein essor
qui attire de plus en plus d'adeptes est
la fin du set 8 journal cette édition et
ses reportages sont à retrouver sur
notre application mobile et sur notre
site internet belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]